you want vents for what happens if you
have me say goodbye here
I don't know how to think
you've gotta see my life
how up are you all you do is give
people reason to hate you I don't know
what you're talking about the cross is
on my mirror I don't know what the
to talk
he's sick of this shit
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Titans Jason Todd under
the Red Hood video they've been setting
him up for an arc it's going way faster
than I ever thought that it would there
was all kinds of Batman Nightwing Easter
eggs so we'll break it down there's a
new DC merch giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Red Hood moment on the
video careful for spoilers for the
recent Titans episodes there's a lot of
stuff that was not in this trailer that
we'll be talking about if you have not
seen those episodes yet looking at the
footage you say Jason Todd showing a
history of reckless behavior which is
accurate to comic book Jason Todd going
in with no backup after dr. light
overconfident underprepared for a threat
as dangerous as Deathstroke there's a
couple of core Teen Titans in Batman
storylines that they're setting up this
season or that they're in the middle of
right now there's death in the family
which is the death of Jason Todd there's
Batman under the Red Hood which is the
birth of Red Hood and then there's Teen
Titans the Judas contract but have you
been watching the episodes you probably
noticed that the characters that they
have on the shows right now are very
different from the characters that were
part of those comic book stories so they
are changing a couple things that I'll
try to point out I think they've been
very clear with the way they're
foreshadowing how their version of under
the Red Hood is going to go it all
starts with Jason Todd being captured by
Deathstroke and used in his larger plan
to separate and slowly destroy each of
the Titans he feels were responsible for
the death of his son Jericho many years
ago really it's Dick Grayson who says
that he's the one that actually did the
job but Deathstroke doesn't care about
technicalities he blames all of the
original Titans so he's got a secret
plan and Jason Todd is just part of it
so while he's sitting here being
captured by a Deathstroke he's busy one
brainwashing him preparing for him to go
back to the Titans Deathstroke wanted
the Titans to rescue Jason Todd he has
contingency plans for that there are
couple scenes in the recent episodes
that indicate Jason Todd has been
brainwashed by Deathstroke programmed to
mess with the other Titans in the next
stage of Deathstroke's plan to sow
dissent amongst the ranks drive them
apart till they all hate each other and
they can't work as a team but it goes
way deeper than that involving the Raven
in the Ravager character so this also
goes back to the beginning of the season
they've been setting up Raven for
something very special that I think is
gonna happen later this season
but a lot of the Ravager stuff that
they're setting up is for potential
Judas contracts storyline but they're
not quite there with the character yet
the way they're playing her she seems
kind of like she has an agenda
she hasn't revealed to them yet but I
don't think she's gone full teri yet not
consciously working for Deathstroke at
least not yet
notice the visual effect that they use
of him remembering his death or
near-death experience over and over
again is designed to look like he's
watching playback on a monitor as if his
mind has been subconsciously playing
back Deathstroke's instructions that's
where you get to him unconsciously
messing with all the other Titans he
remembers things about their past that
he shouldn't know in present day he
doesn't know anything about their past
weaknesses like he puts that bottle of
liquor to mess with hawk he doesn't know
that Hawk is a recovering addict
Deathstroke knows and he programmed that
information into Jason Todd's head what
a coincidence too talking about more Red
Hood Easter eggs that everything in his
hallucinations are colored a strong
Lazarus Pit green just like the Lazarus
Pit that he's brought back in you may
have seen the animated Batman under the
Red Hood movie starring Jensen Ackles
his red hood he's actually dressed up as
live-action Red Hood recently too for
Halloween is awesome as that would be I
don't expect him to actually play a
live-action Red Hood anytime soon but
after Jason Todd was during death
in the family many years later in the
comics it was actually the events of
Infinite Crisis rewriting the reality of
the multiverse that brought Jason Todd
back to life but it brought him back in
this crazed mindless State it wasn't til
Talia al Ghul abducted his body and
tossed him into a Lazarus Pit to restore
his mind that he became the Red Hood as
you saw him the version they went with
in the animated movie just cut out all
that Infinite Crisis stuff it was just
racial ghouls simply taking his dead
body and throwing it into lazarus pit to
bring him back
with all the characters that they have
currently on the Titans TV show it seems
like the version of under the Red Hood
that they're foreshadowing is that Jason
Todd will still wind up dying before the
end of the season but it seems like
they're foreshadowing that Raven is
gonna have something to do with it him
dying based on all four recent episodes
and the lack of control she has over her
abilities she's hooked out several times
this season she technically already
killed ravager at the beginning of the
season
that should have been the first clue
that they're sending up Raven to
accidentally quote-unquote maybe
Jason Todd she hooks out on ravager
breaks her spine the reason why ravager
came back is because she's been dosed
with their version of the mirakuru serum
by hive giving her regenerative
abilities and hands strength speed
agility her body almost instantly heals
all that damage and Raven can't believe
it I'm so sorry I can't believe I lost
control of my abilities but they
continue on in a couple other times
throughout the episodes she loses
control of her abilities and almost
really really hurt someone
more recently brainwash Jason Todd has
been messin with Raven giving her
flashbacks with all those crosses he
draws all over her room making her lose
control just a little bit eventually
making us think that the writers want to
foreshadow that eventually it would be
believable that she could lose control
and kill him accidentally in it's all
part of Deathstroke's diabolical plan to
turn the Titans in on each other if he
can get Raven to accidentally Jason
Todd not only will he break Raven and
break Jason Todd literally he'll also
break the Titans completely but
continuing down the Red Hood arc if they
don't want to do Lazarus Pit ratio ghoul
or Talia for the under the Red Hood
resurrection of Jason Todd they can
always use hive to resurrect him because
they've already introduced hive within
the Titans universe they can inject him
with a special serum that they gave to
ravager that allows her to regenerate
gives her all of her abilities and
turned a resurrected Jason Todd red hood
into their brainwashed weapon until he's
able to shake their programming and go
full red hood in the outlaws and maybe a
future season it would be really really
cool if they could get to a Red Hood in
the outlaws spin-off show but a lot of
this actually seems like it's playing
out this season normally I wouldn't say
that they would try to do an under the
Red Hood storyline until season 3 or
season 4 but they're just pushing along
so quickly post all your Jason Todd Red
Hood origin theories in the comments
below how do you think he's going to die
and who
do you think is going to bring him back
is the Red Hood we're only about halfway
through the season so there's still a
couple characters that they have not
introduced yet and we're getting ready
to see a full-blown Nightwing costume
congratulations vino - OH - you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details
everybody click here for that flash
Batman crossover teaser and click here
for my new Batman movie Riddler and
Catwoman video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you